when a virus winds up inside the body
it's usually met with a furious
onslaught from the immune system white
blood cells immediately respond by
releasing anti viral proteins attacking
infected cells and recruiting backup
usually this is enough
but there's one virus that pushes the
immune system beyond its limits HIV HIV
infects one of the immune cells that is
central to the body's response to
pathogens the helper t-cell first the
virus attaches and enters once inside
the virus moves towards the nucleus
along with its enzymes and genetic
material one of these enzymes reverse
transcriptase converts the viral RNA
into a length of DNA which inserts into
the cell's genome forcing the cell to
spew out HIV proteins and genetic
material to make new copies of the virus
these new viruses escape the cell to
infect others HIV levels rise rapidly in
the body but the immune system doesn't
move down without a fight inside
infected cells anti viral proteins
called restriction factors work to shut
down virus production while others stop
the virus from escaping the cell outside
white blood cells called fiy cells
produce neutralizing antibodies which
bind to surface spikes on HIV particles
and stop them entering healthy helper
t-cells the greatest assault comes from
killer T cells and natural killer cells
which seek and destroy infected cells
directly they release a protein called
perforin which punches the infected
cells allowing enzymes to be injected
triggering Auto destruction for a while
the defense holds and virus levels drop
but HIV begins its counter-attack it
disables the cell's antiviral proteins
allowing new virus particles to leave
the cell it also constantly mutates
inside the cell to evade protection the
immune system can't fight what it can't
see eventually the immune system wears
itself out killer T cells activated for
too long
exhausted and no longer respond to
infection also the body loses the
ability to make new helper t-cells to
replace those killed in the fight and as
a result their numbers plummet
ultimately the body becomes
immunodeficient and this condition is
known as AIDS without treatment exposure
to otherwise harmless microbes can be
fatal
we still have no way of eliminating HIV
from the body completely there is no
cure and hidden reservoirs of HIV will
rebound if treatment stops but treatment
with antiretroviral drugs can swing the
balance allowing the immune system to
recover from battle and live to fight
another day
[Music]